present the award presently what for
cinematography it's like a young dude
who's made movies with Demi Moore Molly
Ringwald and he looks pretty in pink
ladies and gentlemen June prior tongue
you know who year
we all know from personal experience
that the picture is only as good as the
photographer well same can be said for
moving pictures to help you I appreciate
our nominees for Best Cinematography
tonight let me first show you some
cinematography that isn't so good this
is an outtake from the scene in the way
we were now in the cinematographers
defense it still makes people cry but
that's mostly because their eyes hurt
and here's a famous airport scene from
Casablanca someday you'll understand
that
is looking at you kid
this cinematographer suggested they
changed the line to here's not being
able to look at you kid
good cinematographers tend to leave a
little less the imagination and five of
them are nominated for Best
Cinematography the nominees are rip that
open a little too early I'm nervous
folks who Alan Dhabi Oh for the color
purple
mr.william a Fraker for Murphy's romance
mr. David Watkyn four out of Africa
Takaya Sato Masaharu EDA and a sikozu
nakai for Ron
and mr. John Steele for witness and
hilarious mr. David Watkins four out of
Ithaca
a while ago I was sitting in a theater
watching one of my movies next to a
friend of mine who was a film director
and after about an hour he touched me on
the arm and said that's beautiful you're
very clever so I explained that it was a
second unit shot
so perhaps I think it's best if I point
out that the all the flying material was
shot by Peter or work
and the animal photography with Simon
Trevor
I'm truly honored and very flattered and
thank you very much